hello everyone and welcome to some rapid
chess unleashes it's a nice Sunday so
let's play a nice 10 plus Z minute game
uh and uh hopefully we will play some
good moves as usual I will try to
articulate my thought process as as U
you know to the best of my ability and
uh hopefully you those of you who came
here to learn will be able to get
something out of it so our opponent is
uh kesav kav from India rated 232 five
and he goes for the Sicilian Defense
also says Hi in the chat all right hi
there we go we're going to counter it
with Knight F3 and it's a D6 so it's a
pretty standard stuff might be a ner but
then again you never
know uh we'll see what he goes
for and um yeah we're just going for
some rapid development in for those of
you who are new to chess uh we he traded
his cwn for a D Pawn which is good for
him as he eliminates our Central Pawn
for his C Pawn but then again we get a
nice active Square for our Knight in the
center of the board so it's a nice
trade-off uh you know very happy
to very happy to have my knight on
D4 all right so he goes for uh A6 and we
have to figure out how to how to tackle
this um usually H3 is what we went for
so we're going to go for H3 this time as
well well yeah I'll just go
H3 um there are many moves here like any
move you make here is a good move and
uh H3 also but you can also like Play
Bishop E2 Bishop C4 Bishop D3 Bishop E3
Bishop G5 so he goes for H6 which is
fine we're going to go for
G4 uh it's useful as it stops uh White
from uh executing G5 right away he goes
Bishop to E6 he of course wants the have
control over the D5 square and we're
going to play Bishop to
G2 uh later on we can play Knight to G3
if needed and maybe to F5 especially if
he castles King side uh but we're we're
going to do our best to Castle Queen
side and the Knight is now coming to C5
which is very nice we're going to we're
going to play Bishop E3 yeah Queen D2
fairly standard stuff and the bishop uh
okay Pawn comes to B5 right
away now I don't know if
uh yeah if A3 should be played here but
I'm going to play it uh as I I I don't
see why not he he will play Queen A5 he
has the bishop attacking A2 uh also
stops B4 definitely makes sense oh so he
decides to deviate from Knight C5 he
wants to get the Knight to C4 uh which
is great as my Bishop is no longer
controlling the C4 square and he wants
to attack my Queen and pawn here now do
I have time for for queenside castles
now that's the question he will put a
knight here and uh well if he puts a
knight here he can take our dark Square
Bishop whenever he
wants uh so we might as well we we might
as well just take
it yeah I I can't uh remember if I've
ever seen this done yeah now he will
have some some support for B4 uh but
okay I mean yeah also we have to play F3
at some point or maybe we don't yeah
let's just play Rook
F1 yeah the question is now does does B4
do all that much probably it's probably
a good move now he plays
G5
huh
it's very
interesting so I'm going to go Knight
D5 uh simply to try and try and get him
to capture on D5 uh but also to make uh
B4 an impossible idea also now I'm
covering the A5 Square as well so we're
covering a lot of stuff here and uh I'm
still going to Castle Queen side yeah
okay so he takes
uh we're going to capture with the pawn
of
course and uh now we Castle Queen side
uh without ever having to worry about
Pawn to
B4 uh F2 is defended this is defended
uh yeah okay he can he can Castle King
side but it might
be it's probably even good yeah it's
probably even
good if he if he develops the Bishop
okay so he will shift the other Knight
now uh did he do do we need the castle
or do we go for Knight G3 Knight F5
right
away I mean that Knight on F5 will be an
absolute
monster um but on the other hand the
Knight is guarding D4 so I don't want to
I don't want to really see Queen D4
here
[Music]
um but no Queen D4 Queen D4 isn't really
anything yeah he can play it I'm just
going to Castle Queen side and it's
perfectly fine I don't think we even
need to play for some sort of an attack
here uh if if we have the F5 Square for
our knight uh even if he trades queens
and we go into an end game the Knight on
F5 will be
unstoppable okay what what does the
Knight want here
uh it's definitely a
question
um yeah let's get the Knight to
F5 now Bishop G7 is no longer possible
Bishop to E7 is
possible
um but yeah we'll see I don't see the
immediate
uh upside for having a knight on C5 yeah
Knight A4 is nice but I'm still just
going to
Castle
uh or will
I pretty sure I
will yeah I'm just making sure I'm not
falling for some sort of a silly one
move
tactic uh so still everything nicely
defended might even include King to B1
although
although I I don't think it's super
relevant and he might go okay so he does
go for the bishop move uh not really an
issue not really an issue as the king
cannot
move so we go H4 we go H4 with the idea
of just captures and
captures and if he captures then we go
F4 uh we're destroying the center
okay so now uh the D6 point is a little
bit weak so if we can
somehow uh yeah E4 might be nice but
let's go Rook
here
yeah now if he takes uh he will have
some Bishop to G5 ideas but I always
have I'm always faster with
F4 so G captures isn't really an
issue and F4 okay we we will have to
play King to
B1 uh that's uh definitely the
case Okay so he he wants to be
faster
fine we wanted to put a rook on e4
anyway yeah now Knight C5 might be uh an
okay so what is the what is this
move not really doing all that much okay
but one thing it does misclick he said
he
misclicked okay uh okay ask
back ask back the move
yeah uh yeah I can't retract the move
for
him yeah he has to he has to propose a
take back yeah okay he offers a
draw no uh maybe he misclicked and
offered the
draw uh
yeah I hope we'll get our time back uh
if he asks for a
takeback If he if he
will uh he says I changed my
setting
what I have no idea what that
means oh he he set up uh his options
that no
takebackspace
uh do our usual stuff we're going to
play
the well obviously not that uh I I
actually wanted to play C5 I know no
idea why I played F5 uh but okay I mean
let's uh let's play principal
chess doesn't matter we'll play the
we'll play The Dutch against the
English no idea why I did that yeah
really really funny
stuff okay so yeah let's go let's go E6
with some Bishop to B4 try to get
something
uh sort of a sort of a Nimo Indian with
with F5 why not yeah why
not let's go Bishop
E7 uh yeah really really weird
move but okay I'm pretty sure that uh
you know there is a an opening uh F5
against the
English why
not it actually I mean it it actually
doesn't look that terrible we're going
to play B6 Play Bishop B7 put a knight
on e4 yeah I'm I'm kind of liking this
yeah nothing wrong with this at
all um do we trade Queens no let's keep
it keep it interesting not sure if it's
even possible to trade Queens here
um yeah probably probably Pawn captures
uh will give us a more interesting game
but that also locks our Bishop in
completely we're going to take with the
bishop he'll probably just kick it away
we'll move it back he'll play Bishop
F3 uh we we trade off the bishop so
probably because of that maybe Pawn
captures was the was the more ambitious
way to
play uh
okay yeah that makes sense that makes
sense uh I'll take
it and sort
of
close
this yeah he would love to put a knight
here but if he goes here I'll just take
the pawn so that's not happening and he
can't put the Knight here to go here so
he has to figure out how to do that and
I would like to put my knight where I
would like to put my knight on C5 so he
does doesn't have
this
um but that's easier said than
done let's just get rid of this this
nasty
Pawn
all right if we can get rid of the the
wig D6 pawn and develop our rook and
Knight we should be okay and he will of
course do everything uh in his power to
prevent
that yeah and what what else do we have
here okay so some general General
thoughts about the position
uh yeah he's uh his position is
nice
okay so trying to trying to defend here
and also put some pressure on my on my
king side again nothing wrong with
that
[Music]
um yeah but now now I'm actually
inclined to go
C5
what C5 so we don't have to worry about
Rook captures anymore and then we get
our pieces into the game but the C5
he'll probably go after the bishop here
but we don't
care and we have to care a little bit
since F3 will be an option
then I probably will have to play F5 but
yeah I think C5 is now
okay Knight E2 and then
F4 yeah we have to clear some space for
our Bishop and if he doesn't play that
we just bring our Knight into the game
Knight to D7 Knight to E4 Knight to E5
oh no he will go after the pawn chain
with
B4 very
interesting now yeah if he takes I will
take with the pawn uh might look a
little bit weird but I really don't want
to see a knight uh a knight on D4 and
then going here yeah and he would very
much
would very much love what why why this
bishop move what is
this okay show
me okay Queen
captures
ah okay that's how he traps it ah okay
nice nicely
done nicely
done yeah that's how he traps
it
huh
I will play
F4 I will play F4 uh simply because I
believe he will capture on F4 he doesn't
want to cf3 on the board he doesn't want
to take the rook and cf3 but he will
take it's not
much it's probably not even
good
yeah okay he will take that I will take
here so we have a bishop against a rook
we have a past C
pawn and that's all that we have let's
let's let's make the most of it he will
now try uh to find the cleanest way on
how to trade
down and uh also activate his Rook
because as long okay so this is very
nice stopping any any M
threats good good
move okay so we're going to play Queen
F5
here uh threaten
this and also if he moves The Rook then
we have
some it's not nothing
really yeah Rook here is actually very
nice even force my hand into capturing
the pawn
here or do I just capture
nah yeah he doesn't have
any it it might even be dangerous to to
lift The Rook so he has to figure out a
different way on how to how to defend
this if he plays this I could even trade
Queens maybe but no then okay he
captures I can capture with tempo as The
Rook is attacked and if I can get my
pawns to Connected pass pawns to be
defended like you know like rookie one I
capture he captures I capture uh attack
his Rook where does The Rook go probably
here to prevent me from getting my Rook
into the game uh and to defend the pawn
and then I
can yeah it looks a bit uh looks a bit
too
much there's no way to to gain all the
temp be
needed but yeah I mean I could do it
like Rook A5 I go here sacrifice the
pawn he takes and I push
C4
uh might not be might not be
terrible and well while he can double up
Rooks on the seventh my Bishop here
might be useful in defending all sorts
of checkmating ideas but all in all
objectively he will be better so yeah
okay he's not interested in that he will
just uh offer me a pawn but now with the
Rook on C3 is it uh yeah now it's even
worse to trade
Queens but there's no way for him to
actually defend the pawn so we will
improve our position as much as possible
before
uh yeah he also wants to have the
ability of going Rook G3 so he doesn't
have to worry about
Checkmate
H play C4
here now let's get the pawn one square
further get the pawn one square
further then if he takes we're just
going to attack the Rooks uh yeah we
have to we have to win back material if
we can and know probably it was better
just uh have him you know being being up
the oh sorry I'm I'm I forgot to unmute
Zen mode uh maybe it was better to okay
what is
this oh he will go after the pawn this
way
um
uh he'll probably attack it but he knows
that uh he will he will take it at some
point so maybe over over attacking isn't
the way to
go
um so he might even play
this yeah very
interesting okay so he does attack it
and uh we're going to put the Rook on E8
for the moment
just so you know once everything gets
traded off we have some sort of a threat
here although it's not really a threat
he can just trade everything yeah
captures captures captures and then I
can't take with the queen because Queen
captures and Rook checks he hand he has
Queen back to F1 it's kind of a problem
but still it it's a very annoying uh
Rook to have here he will he will waste
the move probably with with the
pawn
G4 okay not not the first move that
comes to mind
definitely um yeah we're going to force
the trades you'll probably just capture
now yeah he will capture we go
here uh now he has to capture with the
Queen and then he loses the G Pawn which
is not the
best if he wants to capture it if he
doesn't capture it well his Rook is
hanging I know G4 was
probably probably a bit too optimistic
we'll see I like it he's starting to
waste
time
um yeah how do you how do you deal with
the Rook
here do you actually play no he defends
The Rook this way
uh and and attacks my Rook yeah let's
not let's not blunder
that uh but uh Rook Rook
E5 rookie five is game
over yeah something had to
give yeah G4
um G4 a bit too
optimistic okay I could have uh yeah I
don't know if if I should analyze also
the first game which uh we sort of
abrupted but uh yeah okay not really
going to accomplish
anything whatever you play it's mate in
one okay uh so let's analyze this uh
whatever this was
F5 against the
English uh not really sure I mean uh it
probably has a name I'm just going to
check real
quickly what is
this uh I don't want to trick you
guys the Anglo the okay so the Anglo
Dutch defense against the English is F5
so that is obviously what I played um
yeah I play Knight F6 six okay we we had
some E6 action here Bishop to B4 I
thought about it I decided to go for
Bishop to E7 uh seemingly much worse you
know in terms of engine strength uh E3
okay uh I decided to develop my light
Square Bishop by fan King and put a
knight on e4 yeah and I really couldn't
figure out if anything was wrong with
this yeah F captures on e4 obviously the
move and uh you know my Spidey Sense was
telling me this but I I wanted to be
greedy uh and then the immediate D5 yeah
he counters it well I captur captured
and played this yeah and now Rook C8
yeah he has to start shuffling the
Knight right away and then kick away my
Bishop uh I played C6 yeah not the best
yeah Bishop to C4 counters no dc6 is the
way to go yeah he has to play this and
then after I capture Queen B3 check I
move and then Knight attacks the
bishop
okay and then what if I go here he takes
I take he goes here okay with what
idea yeah
okay no I mean this uh I guess it is
better for white but to me it even looks
like something that I would enjoy with
black uh so okay he play Bishop to C4
and now it's 0 0 again so maybe not the
best way to go uh yeah capturing the
Knight tactically the most sound I went
for C5 I thought it'd be nice as he
doesn't have Knight to G5 or Knight to
Knight to D4 B4 I played Knight wow just
question marks question marks but it's
not like a really like a blunder or
anything it's still Z zero position uh
Bishop B5 I played Knight here he
captured it I captured it and Bishop to
C6 he went after my rook and uh yeah now
I played Pawn to F4 yeah just Rook K to
C8 is the way to go uh but I blundered
here uh rather it wasn't a blunder it
was a voluntary sacrifice of the
exchange he went yeah Rook C4 Queen A4 a
little bit better uh I tried some tricky
stuff here none of it seemed to actually
work he play Rook e one yeah not the
best uh but uh yeah Rook e one is the
way to go the move that we discussed
yeah uh he he actually did go for the B
I played Rook E8 and then he played Pawn
to B4 yeah this is a pawn to G4 uh the
the double question mark move and now
I'm just better yeah instead of this
just Rook C to
C1 uh followed by I imagine um Rook e
one uh but yeah he went for for G4 Queen
F3 he went for Rook captures and now uh
is just winning yeah even if he captured
I'm going to oh yeah there was even this
yeah don't worry about the pawn just a
nice and we pick up the queen yeah I
really hope I would have seen that and
not just grab the pawn like some sort of
a pawn Grabber uh but he played Queen
here and I play Rook E4 yeah that's the
the only move that wins by force but
it's uh not not a difficult one the spot
he play Queen here and now it's just
Checkmate yeah so uh not the not the
cleanest session but we did uh we did
okay against a high rated opponent so
you know I'll take it for a nice Sunday
session uh so that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it sorry for a bit of a
longer video but that first game got
interrupted and I thought it'd be nice
to offer a second one uh so yeah as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here both of them will be my um
no I'll make one previous leest session
and the one below that the Allen Turing
video I made yesterday if you haven't
seen it do check it out really wonderful
stuff in there uh and yeah uh hope you
had a nice one uh have a great Sunday
and uh you know see you soon